hello in this video we'll talk about
burkitt lymphoma which is a non-hodgkin
lymphoma generally it affects the b cell
which is one type of immune cell
b cells
over proliferate
and divide rapidly
and they become cancerous
market lymphoma is associated with
impaired immunity and it is fatal if it
is not treated in the early age
it is recognized as one of the fastest
growing cancer in human so it is really
really aggressive
burkitt lymphoma is named after british
surgeon denny burkitt and he found this
phenomena in african children around
1956
point to be noted that in african child
the market lymphoma is majorly
associated with epstein-barr virus
infection though the mechanism is
unclear this is a nice clinical
observation
let us quickly revise the fact
associated with burkitt lymphoma
so bucket lymphoma is associated with
impaired immunity it is one of the most
aggressive cancer forms in human and
market lymphoma affects the b cell
and its characteristic facial feature
which is found as a swallowing jaw is
characteristic of bucket lymphoma found
in africa
now the key player of the
market lymphoma is the b cell
so the b cells eventually give rise to
plasma cells which is a differentiated
form of b cell
and that secretes antibody that helps us
to protect against several pathogens b
cells are developed from the bone marrow
so they are born in the bone marrow they
eventually migrate to the lymph node and
in the lymph node they proliferate forms
forming the germinal center
this basic developmental feature would
help us to understand the
pathophysiology underlying burkitt
lymphoma so let's look at the genetic
anomaly and how it is associated with
the cellular level of defects in
burkitt's lymphoma so let's talk about
the genetic anomaly first
the genetic anomaly is associated with a
translocation event that is happening
between chromosomes 8 and chromosome 14.
so this translocation
leads to
movement of the cmic gene
to the
igg heavy chain locus
so igg
heavy chain is highly expressed in the b
cell because b cells
express those ig receptors on their
surface
that is why enhancer of the ig is highly
highly active in the b cell
now semi gene is normally associated
with cellular growth and cellular
division so obviously if these cmic gene
is influenced
heavily then it can ultimately change
the cellular fate towards a carcinogenic
state right
so let us try to understand what really
happens
in normal situations cmic is under its
own enhancers influence
so
a balanced amount of c mic transcript
would be generated which would
eventually give semi protein
and this is important for normal
cellular growth and development
but under bucket lymphoma
semi gene expression
enhanced
several fold because it has now
located in a
close proximity of ig enhancer
that is why
several
times the
cmic and cmic transcript would be
produced
as a result overproduction of c meat
would be there
and this leads to
division and proliferation of the b cell
and these this this ultimately
leads to the malignant transformation of
the b cell
now burkitt's lymphoma
is diagnosed or one of the diagnosis is
the swallowing lymph node that can be
visualized under the jaw or in the neck
region or in other parts of the body
now in the biopsy the characteristic
appearance of the burkitt lymphoma is
the starry sky pattern and that
particular sturdy sky was a painting of
van gogh where you can see bright stars
appearing in the dark night sky here if
you look at the section look at these
histological sections you can see there
are bright patches of white in an
otherwise purple background and these
are the sturdy sky pattern these white
regions are macrophages which have
engulfed some carcinogenic cells and
debris of that
so that is why this is the
characteristic pattern or diagnosis of
burkitt's lymphoma now let us talk about
the classification of brackets lymphoma
it is subclassified into endemic which
is african version of it primarily it
affects children of age four to seven
and it is associated with epstein-barr
virus infection
now there is a non-african version as
well which is sporadic and this is
constituting the u.s or
western european versions of the markets
lymphoma globally it accounts for one to
two percent of the adult lymphoma cases
the third type is immunodeficiency
associated generally it is common in
patients
who are undergoing scid or aids
and
30 to 40 percent of non-hodgkin lymphoma
in hiv patient is burkitt's lymphoma
so
burkitt lymphoma is highly aggressive
but at the same time it is treatable if
the treatment starts in early ages
so the key challenge in burkitt lymphoma
treatment is the diagnosis part if the
diagnosis is early enough
with proper chemotherapy and other
sometimes bone marrow transplantation it
can be cured
so as per summary we have looked at the
cellular and molecular basis of
burkitt's lymphoma we looked at the
diagnosis of burkitt's lymphoma and we
also explored some amount of treatment
options in burkitt's lymphoma if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow me on instagram
facebook or in twitter my id is
urbanporicha and you can
support my channel in patreon so be my
patreon and if you like this video give
it a big thumbs up don't forget to
comment and let me know how you are
liking my videos if you have a
suggestion also put it in the comment
thank you